a central Nevada man is recovering in a
Las Vegas hospital after suffering Burns
in a hot spring it happened two weeks
ago in round Mountain that's about 300
miles Northwest of Las Vegas David
knack's dog jumped in the hot spring he
went after her eight news now reporter
Joshua peguero spoke exclusively to the
man's wife because he is facing a very
long road to recovery
Mary Lou Knack wants the world to know
about her husband he went in because
he's a hero and he's
Brave and courageous and
the biggest is the biggest heart and he
would do that for anyone but he did it
for our dog
their German Shepherd had jumped into a
hot spring David Knack touched the water
with his foot and realized it was
scorching but overwhelmed by watching
his dog whimper and cry he went into the
water be aware that
dogs are
fun but they're very
and they kill they kill animals and
people
since Tuesday October 25th David has
been at the UMC Burn Center receiving
treatment for his second and third
degree burns Sasha unfortunately died on
the way to the veterinarian David was
flown by helicopter from round Mountain
to Las Vegas we need help from
help there is a GoFundMe and venmo
accountant set up to help them cover
David's medical expenses and the amount
of time he will miss from work as a
minor she left the this world knowing
that
he would do anything for her